tonight in the trial of Oscar Pistorius
a neighbor describes a call from the
athlete minutes after he shot his
girlfriend he said please please come to
my house please
I shall Viva her thought she was a
include er a friend tells the trial how
Pistorius begged her to save reeva
Steenkamp slice please Chris please can
we we just put in a car and get it to
the hospital good evening from the Oscar
Pistorius murder trial here in Pretoria
after a two-week break in proceedings
the athlete was back in court and the
trial entered a critical new phase first
the defense called his neighbor Johan
stander who was also the estate manager
he was the first person to arrive at the
house and described how he saw the
athlete coming down the stairs holding
his dying girlfriend in his arms mr.
stander said he'd raced to the scene
after getting a call from the runner
telling him he'd shot free the Steenkamp
after thinking she was an intruder
the court also heard from mr. Stander's
daughter a friend of the athlete who
described how the sportsman begged her
to save his girlfriend's life Paul
Harrison has been following today's
proceedings
morning mr. Pistorius just get some rest
after a 17-day hiatus it was back to
court for Oscar Pistorius first falling
into the arms of a supporter then thrust
back in time to the early hours of
Valentine's Day 2013
the athletes friend Johan stander who
was also the manager of the estate where
the Paralympian lived had been woken
early by Pistorius body she saved the
court from mr. Pistorius he said on the
call
woman please please please go come to my
house please I shot Viva I sure I
thought she was an intruder please
please come quick
my daughter kind out of her room and she
said she just heard somebody screamed
well my wife thought my daughter yes
what's mr. Bhatt must be mr. miss story
as he called your dad and said said he
shot Eva first of the scene together
with his daughter
mr. stander whom Pistorius called uncle
described coming face to face with a
broken man when mr. Pistorius saw us
there was a relief on his face when he
reached the bottom of the stairs I think
my daughter asked him to put River down
he keep on asking us he was crying he
was really crying we kept on he was
really crying was he was in pain and he
asked us to please assist him to put
reeve on a car and take it to the
hospital
mr. Sonya Cerf your emotional take your
time
my daughter asking to put cleaver down
on the floor he did
we try to calm mr. to the stories down
he was broken he was screaming he was
crying he was crying and it's not
something that I would like to
experience again my lady was that young
man walking the other stairs with a lady
the young woman in his arms and the
scene to see the expression on his face
the expression of sorrow the expression
of pain is crying his prime he's asking
God to help him he was doing apart
broken desperate
bleeding
it's difficult really to describe and
his commitment to save the young lady's
life when it put his finger in his mouth
and tried to keep the airway open want
to breathe how he begged to stay with
him I saw the truth it is more that
morning I saw it and I feel it Oscar
Pistorius argues he had an inherent fear
of intruders his legal team sought to
justify his concerns do you know of any
incidents of crime that was reported to
have taken place within the estate's
other words that is yes I do my lady
this is in the street Mulk word why I
think there was three incidents the one
incident was a lady was tied up the
other incident was the user ladder to
get up to his house into into into their
house and there was a third incident in
that street right in the corner the
incidence of Hef but it was never
reported to the police the owner didn't
want reporter in cross-examination
prosecutor heavy Nell pounced on the
defense witness when he appeared to
deviate from his written statements he
never said to you it was an accident
when he found me said on my demands like
no you can't say that because we asked
you all just before we started you said
you remember 100% why do you want to add
things now no subpoena court we said oh
my on please come to mouth please please
please
I'm short River I thought she was mean
CUDA
yes why do you want to include
that he said she made misleading mistake
that was a mistake for me why would you
make such a mistake do you want to
assist mr. studios in his defense or why
would you make such a mistake
no mister my lady I I'm yet to give the
truth and I think I gave the truth what
I experienced that morning but ignore my
statements first and second statements
and that's it also choosing to give
evidence off-camera mister Stander's
daughter carries fillion told the court
this story is begged her to take reeva
Steenkamp to hospital and pleaded with
God for her not to die I walked in and
the first thing I saw was asked carrying
Riverdance days you can see he was he
was a rookie rather fast and from the
second that we walked into that house
like he was frantic when he saw us he
just kept on carisi please carisi please
can we can we just put in a call and get
it to the hospital and he just he just
wanted to get it to the hospital and I
told him to no can you please when he
got it to the bottom of the stairs on
that just put a dart just put it down as
we could just see what's what's wrong
I'm sorry my lady I apologize no I just
don't just take your time he was begging
me to put in the cards as I could sauce
that's all maybe you should just stop
just give me a sec it's my lady's heart
now promise I'll be fine maybe I have
some
the moment he saw me he immediately I
just say secrecy please thank you very
much can we take it to the hospital can
we please just take it to the hospital
just take my car keys just put in the
car and that's all that I'll just put it
down so as we meet at the bottom of the
stays he just put it down right there
and I told him if we just need to see
what's going on - because I just saw
blood everywhere I was kneeling on the
one side of Aviva and Oscar was kneeling
on the other side and he just kept on
begging he's like please can we just
take you to the hospital my god we've
only the ambulance just wait at least to
see what we can do and we said okay well
then we need to start stop the bleeding
and at that stage I proceeded up the
stairs to the landing at the top of the
house where his linen closet is and I
grabbed a few towels I came back down
and he was still he was praying to God
the whole time to just save a lot he was
he was begging and pleading with Reva as
well - please stay with him and so not
you have to stay with me my love stay
with me we tried to stop the bleeding
and and we tired the towel tried to tie
it I remember Oscar still had to help me
because it was rather difficult to tie
the towels and he was holding the one
side I was holding the other side and we
tied it and then then we also lift up
her pens here because I could see there
was blood yet as well and we pushed it
engage your point duty right heap yes
during this most of the time he had his
finger in her and her mouth as well
trying to help her to breathe our
surprising because at a stage when when
I asked him to fetch the tape or the
bags to help me to talk he asked me if I
can please just keep my finger they just
keep your finger they finger we're in
her mouth
and cure this whole time it was Epson
asking me where's the ambulance with
ambulance we all they please greasy way
or they're begging me and I just keep on
telling them they're coming they're
coming
Oscar please they're coming and I mean
we just tried our very best asker
pistorius's friend and neighbor curry
civilian continued her evidence and was
cross-examined by the state prosecutor
but harry Nels demeanor wasn't as
traumatic as previously seen when you
arrived at the house they were like ah
yes my lady lady the kitchen light was
on did you better watch she did Packer
watch my lady in there in Oscars bedroom
a lady who you were you with it yes my
lady I was with her and there was a
policeman with you yes is the one girl
that fell out whilst you were getting
Patel's out of the cupboard do you wait
there you Fitch tells the one found out
yes money I might just say my lady I did
not the gentleman was they making sure
that we don't go into the bathroom you
spoke to Oscar that morning did you make
other phone calls with that you would he
wouldn't have been able for him to mypos
without you knowing m'lady when I was
with him I didn't see him making other
any other phone calls
except that one to Justin Jason and then
odd which phone who I then took over and
then I made the other two and that was
it what I could see my lady and you
remained with him until the time that he
was moved from the kitchen to the garage
m'lady there was a time where I stepped
outside my father was outside and then I
would
back in m'lady can you remember what
happened to the cellphone when the case
was moved to the garage no m'lady I
cannot did you see that cell phone again
m'lady I saw a cellphone in the garage I
don't know if it was the same phone
milady I can't say now the cell phone
you saw in the graph is also in a
charger if I remember correctly there
was a phone in the garage on a charge on
my lady you gave evidence about the kids
being distressed crying praying and so
forth but it was his idea for you to get
towels is that not sir
she gave a towel to stop the bleeding
well I wouldn't say it was his idea I
think it was everything just happened
together and we were like we need to
stop the bleeding now head to town when
you asked him to get plastic bags and
tape he specifically asked you to put
your finger in the mouth to keep that
Airways open he did m'lady he was
following what's going on thank you sir
well he asked questions but he was it
was everything was in a frantic State
m'lady so I wouldn't know if he was
following what was happening he just
kept on asking but if you gave him an
instruction he would follow it yes he
would
here to discuss the first day back in
court after a two weeks recess is Debora
patta South African journalist and our
own legal expert Llewellyn Kalu's let's
talk about these two witnesses the first
two people on the scene immediately
afterwards Johan stand Oh who's the
residential estate administrator or a
part of the administration previously
and his daughter what do you make of
them Debora less testimony I think their
strongest witnesses the defense has had
I mean we had Oscar Pistorius testifying
in his own defense it was a dismal poor
performance he really battled on the
stand
we had Roger Dixon who you know almost
became a laughingstock the geologist who
tried to talk about ballistics but these
two were credible they were strong and
they obviously have been called in to
testify to pistorius's state of mind
that he did indeed shoot reeva Steenkamp
according to them because he thought
that she was a Buddha left left sound
bike really from your hands stander when
he said I thought it I saw it almost
trying to save it believed him
and he said I felt it was the truth I
was watching and witnessing the truth
Llewellyn he also made some crucial
points about particularly about dr.
snips ever do with what Deborah said
from my perspective they were credible
witnesses I was impressed with the
demeanor especially of the daughter
curious Fillion I thought she was a
wonderful witness for the defense one
must ask ourselves what did they
contributed to the case because from a
legal perspective there are a couple of
issues that must be addressed and the
proof is in the pudding very indicated
that he will call experts to come and
testify and corroborate certain aspects
which we're still waiting to do but for
now let's look at the two witnesses
first of all standard confirmed the
state of mind as portrayed by the
defense from the outset that he that's
the first thing and that was
corroborated by his daughter as well and
and also that his version that he
thought she was a burglar also came out
because he was the very first person
that received the call from Oscar and
the version by Oscar was corroborated by
this very first witness so what
if we assume that that's probably the
correct stood what was said to him I
consider another possible version before
court so that is the second thing then
there was the issue with regard to the
alarm system be mindful of the fact that
Oscar Pistorius couldn't answer that
question properly in cross-examination
exactly the testimony is that for some
time she she looked after his house
while he was in the cape province or
something to that effect fact of the
matter is that is so now suddenly we
have a reasonable explanation for her
being there and she was knowledgeable
with their workings of the alarm system
so at least death issues also now sorted
out and then lastly as far as I'm
concerned with regard to his evidence it
was the issue with regard to the the
sounds now there's a bit of a
discrepancy in the state's version now
suddenly because stander indicated that
step told him that there was four shot
sounds he that's what he heard and then
suddenly there was a shouting of some
kind and another four shots now that is
not the way we understood the evidence
from step when he testified so obviously
some kind of a doubt and remember once
we have doubt the defense and the
accused must get the benefit of the
doubt so Deborah what to do make of
curry fil hoon and how she handles Harry
Nell
because Harry Nell does the Bulldog
prosecutor seemed to be completely
bowled over by she read straight away
and said you know please don't show me
those photographs in case they make me
cry you're gonna make me cry she said
and kind of bought a bit of light relief
almost to the courts of acknowledging
that this was a fierce person she was up
against and he then handed her with kids
laughs although I suspect that was
always going to be his strategy it seems
to me that the prosecution wasn't unduly
worried by these witnesses and whilst
they give credence to pistorius's
argument they weren't they when it
happened and so really what the judge is
also going to look at and I don't know
what you think is the facts of the
actual shooting incident it's going to
be interesting because I understand on
the defense that they hope to call a
neighbor who will testify very
differently to other neighbors so when
we start to see that kind of evidence
strong countering of
the prosecution's case I think it'll be
a different case and then I think we're
gonna see now getting back to his
Bulldog State Harry Nell is supposed to
be a prosecutor not a persecutor so
remember he also wants that the truth to
come out that is the B's main and sole
purpose in this case it's not a him
personally against having a vendetta
against rue he must see to it that
justice is done and to that extent you
can kill somebody with kindness and I
think it was a wonderful approach by the
witness to suggest him I'm going to tell
you what I know and that's it so please
don't be that bulldog in quotation marks
that everybody thinks you are I'm not
that I would stand for it and I will
tell you what happened and just but as
you both pointed out their testimony
isn't the as crucial it may be is good I
don't think it's gonna make or break the
case for us good the stories I mean
there's a lot more that's gonna come up
obviously they go to use it because I
it's interesting that step could be used
to support the defense case or he could
be used to support the prosecution case
they're obviously going to try and turn
his evidence to support and their
version of events and that's what we saw
Lou trying to do in his
cross-examination and of course one of
the points that Barry Roos team made was
that these two were initially on the
state's witness list and weren't used
with the inference being that they
weren't considered back at the state's
case our bodies but just on that make no
mistake that doesn't necessarily imply
that suddenly one must be mindful and
say but listen therefore negative
inference must be must be make out of
that because a member of us I indicated
last time around to you as well Alex
that in terms of our law the moment the
Prosecuting Authority closed their case
the state and they allow the defense to
call the remainder of the witnesses on
the list if they want to then no
negative inference can be made out of
that because they are available the only
reason why I decided not to call them
because we still I've already proved my
case so there's no need for me to take a
risk in calling further witnesses
however for in order for me heading out
to make sure that they can't be negative
inference
for later on I put it out there and I
actually invite the defense to call them
if they want to do so now suddenly the
defense must make up their mind are they
going to take that risk or not because
calling them knowing very well there are
in actual fact previously known as state
witnesses are they going to assist my
case or not sometimes definitely not so
there's no reason for me to call him if
I if they are available I don't call
them then on par Harry nails great to
say but why didn't you call him if you
thought they're going to assist you so
let's not make too much about that given
the speed that it suddenly picked up
we'd look like we're probably on on
course to finish by mid-may I think so I
think we're getting there the defense
will wrap up its case by the six
stealing everyone's so exhausted in a
way and and the main sort of bulk of the
case has been done and then they'll take
a break to prepare closing arguments
which I understand will be fairly Swift
once they start arguing it will be an
executive summary because the judge
would have the written documents and we
should get a verdict pretty soon after
that well yet more interesting days to
come thank you very much Llewellyn
Kalu's Debora patta remember to watch
continuing coverage of the Pistorius
trial on Sky News every day and our
special catch-up program every night at
9:30
you